[Music]
[Music]
I'm John Guttag and today it's my
pleasure to introduce the speaker
professor Barbara Liskov who did not
give me her BIOS so I'm gonna have to
fake it Barbara has been on the faculty
for least longer than I have and I've
been here 25 years or so we've been in
the faculty 26 maybe she started when
she was 15 is a well-respected expert on
programming languages distributed
systems fault-tolerant systems and a
host of other topics and I think with
that I'll just turn it over to you and
turn off my microphone
okay so I'm going to talk today about
providing secure services on the
internet and as I'm sure you're all
aware we are becoming more and more
dependent on information that's stored
online and expand access to over the
Internet
truly critical information is kept
online and it's very important that this
information be stored securely and I'm
particularly interested in two
properties of security so this is not
exactly the standard definition of
security I'd like the information that
you store to be accessible to you
whatever you wanted and furthermore I
want it to be uncorrupted so that you
can actually use it and I'd like these
properties to be preserved for you in
spite of all the kinds of problems that
can happen and in particular I'm
interested in hardware failures software
errors and malicious attacks and as you
know malicious attacks particularly are
becoming more and more something that
happens on the Internet
so here's some examples of the kind of
online information that I'm concerned
about you might have a log of your
credit card entries being kept by your
credit card company and it's very
important that that information not be
corrupted so that for example the
charges that you think you have incurred
don't change mysteriously another
example is a key distribution service
that's used allows you to look up
somebody's name and get back a public
key that you can then use to access some
information yet another example is DNS
the domain name server which is the
source of all addressing on the Internet
and if the DNA DNS name servers are
corrupted you won't be able to find
anybody that you would like to talk to
on the Internet and then another example
is simply a company's website the for
example recently I read in the news that
the staples website had been hacked into
and everybody that went to look at the
staples website was immediately
forwarded to the website of a competitor
so you may not think that the company
website is such an important thing but
even there a corruption of data through
a malicious attack can be a big problem
and as a matter of fact these problems
are becoming increasingly evident and
what you see in the news is just a small
sort of tip of the iceberg of what's
really going on because when when
critical data is kept online the owners
of this data are very interested in not
having you know that there's been an
attack that's caused that data to become
corrupted now my concern in this talk is
can be what's called data integrity in
other words I want to make sure your day
is available and it's uncorrupted there
are a whole bunch of other security
issues that are obviously also very
important for example privacy you would
like to be sure that your credit card
logs can't be looked at by people that
you don't that aren't supposed to see
them and access control the ability to
control who has the right to look at
certain information I'm not going to
talk about those so as I mentioned
before there are sort of three main
reasons why integrity might be
compromised
first of all hardware might fail but in
addition there can be bugs in your
software and finally we can have
malicious attacks and the way that you
survive these kinds of problems is by
replication so replication the basic
idea is that if one of the copies of the
information is hacked into or destroyed
you can still provide access to it
because there are all those other copies
and of course for this to work this
means that the replicas that make up the
replicated system are going to be have
to carrying out some kind of protocol
that guarantees that they are in sync
with one another so that the information
you get from the backup copy if the
primary fails is up-to-date with respect
to what the primary has stored now
traditional fault tolerance which was a
topic of great research interest in the
80s was concerned with a particular sort
of replication algorithm that was
designed to define to survive what are
called fail stop failures so fail stop
failures are a very simple kind of
failure compared to what we'll be
talking about in this talk because the
idea here is that when a failure happens
the way it manifests itself is that
things simply stop so for example a
computer something
wrong with the hardware and the computer
simply stops functioning or well so
that's an example of a fail stop failure
and these failures are relatively easy
to cope with because you essentially
have to worry only about the question of
what do I do if I can't hear from
somebody and you don't have to worry
about the problem of I'm hearing from
this entity but it's not telling me the
right stuff so in the 80s people
concentrated on fail stop failures and
there were actually two reasons for this
one is was at that time hardware wasn't
all that reliable and so this was
considered to be sort of the major thing
you had to be concerned about and the
other reason was that this seemed hard
enough we didn't understand how to build
replication systems that could survive
even these simple failures and so
tackling the much more difficult
failures that I'm going to talk about
today was sort of way beyond what we
could think about doing to survive
simple fail stop fail you should require
two F plus one replicas and I'm going to
show you why that's true for example to
survive one failure you're going to need
three replicas and and then when you run
your operations each operation is going
to have to sort of check in with at
least two of those replicas and we're
going to have to ensure that these
operations are totally ordered so that
if you say modify the replicated service
twice the second replication the second
modification doesn't sort of forget what
happened in the first one and that's
going to require a two-phase protocol so
in the case of fail stop failures you
can get by with two F plus one replicas
and you can carry out a two-phase
protocol and I have a little example
here to show you why sort of what's
going on and why you need to F plus one
replicas so for example this green
circle might represent the operation
that executes right now and it happens
to manage to be carried out at these two
blue replicas and then at some time in
the future another operation is carried
out and for some reason it isn't able to
communicate with this replica but
instead I guess I should be using I see
yes that there wasn't really very
effective was it
all right now if I just knew how to use
this okay okay so so in this green
circle is where the first operation was
executed and for some reason that only
executed at those two blue replicas and
then at a later time the red operation
was executed and for some reason it
wasn't able to communicate with this
replica but was able to be carried out
with these two replicas the point is
that because we had two F +1 replicas
and or rather three replicas in this
example and because each operation
happened at two of them we can be
certain that the two operations overlap
in one place and that's going to be
sufficient for us to make sure that the
later operation reflects the effects of
the earlier operation provided we carry
out the proper protocol so for example
supposing this was a key distribution
centre and what's M system and what was
happening was for some reason two
entries were being made for the very
same name in a very close period of time
so the green operation inserted some
public key for that name and then a few
seconds later the red one inserted a
different later public key for the very
same name or rather let me rephrase that
supposing that the first one did it for
name one and the second one did it for
name too and what's going on in these
operations is you're rewriting the
database to reflect the most current set
of entries you want to be sure that that
second operation writes back the right
result for the first operation as well
as the right result for itself so that's
an example of why we need a two-phase
protocol we have to have one face that
finds out what happened before and a
second phase that reflects that as well
as the changes that are being made I'm
not going to go into the various
algorithms that people invented to carry
out this kind of simple protocol I just
wanted to point out primarily that you
need to F +1 replicas and a two-phase
protocol yes that F plus 2 won't work so
if we had F plus 2 then in the case of 2
failures we'd have 4 replicas now so
then you have to ask the question well
how many replicas are involved in each
carrying out of the operation because
the requirement is going to be that you
have these overlapping sets in each
subsequent operation so with four
replicas you would only be able to
survive one failure because you'd have
to carry out the operations at carrying
out a to operate two replicas wouldn't
be sufficient to get that overlapping
property so no you don't you don't
necessarily know that okay what you know
is that these are the ones I was able to
talk to right now and you would like to
be assured that at least one of them
knows about the most recent things that
have happened in the past no because in
the case of a of a system within the
internet you can't really tell the
difference between a failure and a lack
of a response okay okay so all right so
that's how things were in the 80s and
the problem is that those fail stop
failures are only the sort of a tip of
the iceberg and what we'd really like is
replication algorithm to survive Morse
much more serious failures those fail
stop failures really only correspond to
hardware failures where the system
effectively crashes and it doesn't they
it doesn't match what happens when you
have a software error which can
sometimes cause your system to fail and
yet continue to run and it also doesn't
have to cover what happens when there's
a malicious attack like that example of
staples that I mentioned a few minutes
ago so those kinds of failures can cause
your system to stop acting properly and
yet continue to carry out a protocol
that can fool the other replicas into
thinking that that node is perfectly
okay
and what happens when you start to think
about failures like this is it becomes
very Byzantine you sort of have to think
that everybody's scheming to make things
misbehave in the sort of worst possible
way whatever answer you get from
somebody is a lie and therefore you have
to have replicas you have to replication
techniques that are capable of surviving
in spite of all those lies provided
there haven't been too many of them okay
and these are in fact the majority of
faults today they may not mannequin
themselves as Byzantine failures but
there's no doubt that failure is due to
software errors and malicious attacks
are the primary reason that we have
failures today okay so what I'm going to
do today is I'm going to talk about how
you can survive Byzantine failures I'm
going to describe a new replication
algorithm to you that survives Byzantine
failures and has very good survival
properties and furthermore it's
practical performs well and I'll show
you a little bit of performance
evaluation results to show you what's
going on
all right so the in contrast to the
simple fail stop failures that I talked
about a minute ago when you have
Byzantine failures you require more
replicas and more phases in your in your
replication protocol so you require
three F plus one replicas to survive F
failures so for example to survive one
failure you now need four replicas not
three and furthermore your replication
protocol has to have three faces in it
not two phases okay
and when we started this work it was
already known that you needed three F
plus one replicas to survive F failures
that was had been proved earlier our
algorithm is more efficient than
algorithms that people have invented
before so and I don't know about a
minimality proof that would show you
require three phases though I certainly
haven't been able to think of a way of
doing it with fewer okay now the
algorithm and I'm going to describe for
you provides what's called state machine
replication and this is what you really
want the idea is that you have a service
an arbitrary service typically provides
access to its services by means of
operations that clients can call so for
example in a file system you can ask to
read and write entire files you can also
read and write directories rename and so
forth and in a key distribution center
you could store a new pair you could
read a pair and so on so anything that
you think about can be phrased in this
form and really what I'm talking about
here is data abstraction so you're
talking about arbitrary services that
provide operations that allow users to
make use of their services at the level
of abstraction that makes sense for that
application
and one of the nice things about state
machine replication in addition to
the fact that it sort of matches the way
that people really do their business is
that it will allow us to provide service
in spite of Byzantine faulty clients now
a client this is the node that's trying
to use the service if the client is
storing for example bad data in a file
we can't do anything about that access
controls the mechanism that you would
use to try and at least guarantee that
whoever's writing that file has the
right to write it but what we can do
with state machine replication is we can
make sure that the client doesn't sort
of get stopped halfway through and leave
the system in such a bad state with its
invariants broken and so forth that
you're sort of not able to continue your
business so it's really very nice to be
able to provide state machine
replication rather than the simpler
thing that many people have worked on
which is simply the ability to read and
write single words with reading writing
single words you have to implement in
some sense the higher level of semantics
at the client machine itself and then
you interact with the service by doing
reads and writes in sequence ok so
here's basically I'm just going to try
and show you here what it is we have to
do in this algorithm in order to make it
work so in state machine replication
what you do is you assume that the
operations are deterministic in fact you
require them to be deterministic and
furthermore you make sure that the
replicas all start up at the beginning
of time in the same state and then
assuming that the replicas execute the
same request in the same order ok you
will know that correct replicas will
produce identical results so the key
thing here is this thing here because
what this is telling me is what my
protocol has to accomplish I have to be
sure in my protocol to guarantee that
all the non faulty replicas execute the
same operations in the same order it's
the usual thing in other words if you
call that operation with the same
arguments I'm sure there's a trick here
somewhere ok that it should produce the
same results so for example file systems
are sort of deterministic except that
whenever you read a file you get
time last modified or time last read
that gets set that's a non deterministic
effect and so to do a simple file system
we're gonna have to play some sort of
trick that makes sure that we that all
the replicas will set the site at the
same time last read okay so there's
nothing nothing unusual going on here
determinism is the same old thing we're
accustomed to to rephrase that if you're
in the same state and you operate the
same X operation you should come out
with the same result
at some level of abstraction definitely
the level of abstraction okay so the key
is going to be that thing I highlighted
that's what the protocol has to
accomplish and it's not easy okay so
what are the clients do I'm gonna start
talking about them first of all they
carry out a little protocol of their own
they send their requests to all the
replicas and then they wait for F plus
one identical replies and the reason
that works is because we're talking
about a system that can survive F
failures okay so you have to assume that
there are most F faulty replicas in the
system at this moment so F of these
replies might be total lies but one of
them is coming from an on faulty replica
and therefore we know that we have one
replica that said this is the answer and
we can rely on that yeah
I haven't showed you the protocol okay
all I'm showing you is what the client
does so yes we have to ensure that the
answer given us by that one non faulty
replica is it is a true answer so we're
going to need a protocol that will
ensure that that's correct
now remember it's identical answers so
we're going to the light we can't rely
on any F of these guys but we can rely
on the group of them because one of them
is not telling us a lie okay but I
haven't showed you the protocol yet I've
just showed you what the client does
okay so what are the replicas do well
they have to carry out a protocol that
ensures that those replies from the non
faulty replicas are actually correct and
that requires that enough right replicas
process each request right to ensure
that you know the non faulty replicas
are processing the same request in the
same order and in particular to sort of
answer your question an on faulty
replica will never send an answer to a
request that it hasn't achieved by
carrying out this protocol okay so it
doesn't really matter what those liars
said because we know we can rely if we
have F plus one answers at least what's
one must be honest and the protocol was
enough to ensure that that was the right
answer okay so now I'm going to go into
the heart of the protocol and tell you
in a sort of a hand-wavy sense you know
how we manage to do this so the first
thing I want to point out is that we are
using a particular kind of protocol a
kind of primary backup scheme and what
that means is that at any moment in time
the group of replicas as a whole is in
what's called a view of you in this
system is a very simple thing it just
means that in this view one of the
replicas acts as the primary and the
remainder of backups and actually we
achieve this in a very simple way a view
has a view number associated with it and
the primary is simply the the node whose
replica ID modulo the view number is one
you know so we choose it in a very
simple minded way okay so the main point
is that the view designates who the
primary is and the primary is the one
that's going to determine the
ordering of the requests the advantage
of a primary scheme is that one guy gets
to choose the order otherwise we'd have
to have some sort of agreement protocol
in which we'd all be choosing the orders
and somehow voting on it and that's more
expensive so the primary chooses the
order but the problem is in a system
like this
the primary might be a liar and so the
order that it's choosing may not be the
proper order and therefore the backups
have to ensure that the primary behaves
correctly so the backups are checking up
on what the primary is doing if they
don't like the order that the primary is
suggesting they won't go along with it
and then that will trigger what's called
a view change which will go to a higher
view number and they'll different note
will become the primary in that new view
so the way we survive failures in this
system is by doing these view changes
which change who the primary is and the
system will work as long as no more than
F replicas are faulty ok so now the
system is based on two notions quorums
and certificates a quorum I actually
showed you a quorum earlier when I
talked about the simpler system yes Ron
I'm really only talking about malicious
servers but the client messed up the
database in some ways and not in others
remember it could write bad data into
the file and we'd have to solve that
problem through access control but the
client isn't able to cause file reads to
misbehave in some fundamental sense
because it doesn't have the ability to
execute a file read it just is able to
ask for a file read to happen or a file
write he can't cause inconsistency to
write bad data to a file and this would
show up inconsistently at all the
replicas he can't cause a file to become
inconsistent at the replicas and that's
precisely what you're getting out of the
fact that this is a state machine
replication system okay so we can sort
of survive faulty clients but not really
because of course it's very bad if you
write bad data to the file but that
no different from a unreplicated system
in which somebody writes bad data to a
file okay so in my earlier discussion of
the non Byzantine failure case remember
we had two F + 1 replicas and every
operation had to be carried out at two
of them or rather at F plus one of them
and that's what's called a quorum so a
quorum in these systems is a set of
replicas that's big enough that it
overlaps with the next set of replicas
that carries out the next operation now
in this system
corms have to have at least two F plus 1
replicas and to understand why that's
true we need to look at what happens
when you execute an operation and so
again what I'm showing you here is a
system with one that will survive one
failure so it's got four replicas in it
and we have our little green operation
there that executed at these 3 replicas
ok and and so and so that was a quorum
and it succeeded in executing and then
we executed our second doesn't really
matter which is which operation later
using a different set of three replicas
okay now since we have two F plus 1
replicas in a quorum this means two
forms will intersect in F plus one
replicas ok and that's very important
because at any moment in time one
replicas could be faulty ok so that
guarantees the chorim's always intersect
in at least one non faulty replicas and
that's what it is that guarantees that
whatever happened in the earlier
operation can be reflected in the later
operation because that truth will be
carried through the one non faulty
replica ok another way of looking at
this picture is think about what
happened when we executed this operation
here it looked like three replicas
carried it out but this grey guy might
very well have been a liar ok and the
blue guy that we didn't hear from might
simply have been a slow you know but non
faulty replicas ok so the fact that we
got a quorum doesn't mean that everybody
in the quorum is telling us the truth
and so we have to have big enough forums
to take
that problem they actually talk to
everybody now I'm gonna in the next
slide I'm gonna walk through how we sort
of carry out this protocol okay so
that's what a quorum is and they're big
enough so that chorim's always intersect
in at least one non faulty replica okay
the other thing that we use in the
algorithm is what's called a quorum
certificate and that's just a set of
messages that a replica accumulates from
a quorum
identical messages from a quorum so all
messages in the quorum will agree on the
same statement and I'm going to show you
what these statements are like when I go
to the next slide okay so here's how we
order requests here we have a request
coming in from a client and the client
sends that request to the primary now in
reality the client might send it to some
of the other replicas also but it goes
to the primary and the primary is
responsible for choosing the sequence
number so the sequence number for the
requests is going to be the order in
which they're executed so the primary
receives this request it says this is
going to be requests 123 okay and it
broadcasts that information to all the
other replicas so that's what's
happening in this part of the picture
now this little thing down here
indicates that the whole thing is
encrypted okay and in fact we use
cryptography on every single messages
exchange in this system one thing that
happens is even this request M that's
coming from the client is encrypted with
a secret key that is known to the
replicas for that client and here we're
using the secret key that the primary
uses to communicate with the other
members of the group okay in fact we use
what's called an Authenticator there
because there's a different secret key
for every member of the group of the
client of the primary's talking to and
we're going to broadcast this message
and we're using secret key cryptography
here because it's much cheaper than
public key cryptography but these secret
keys need to be changed periodically and
so they're backed up with public keys
and private keys that can be used to
exchange new keys okay so the primary
picks a sequence number for that message
and ships it off to everybody
and it's all encrypted so that we can
make sure that it's when it arrives it's
uncorrupted and it came from the primary
and so forth okay now when a replica
receives one of those messages it
carefully checks it over to make sure
that it likes it and it will never a
correct replica will never accept two
messages that pick the same sequence
message sequence number for different
client requests so if a replica ever
received from a primary another thing
saying here's another number 127 it
won't accept the second one okay and it
also checks other things about it make
sure that the client message is really
uncorrupted and so forth and so on yeah
they're global they're global so the
view change is going to have to preserve
the sequence numbers going forward okay
all right so the primary has chosen that
number and now let's imagine that
arrived at some replicas and the
replicas looked at it and everything
looked ok it had never received a 127
before the prime the client message was
in good condition and so forth so then
what it does is it immediately sends out
messages to every other replica saying
I'm happy with that number for this
client request so that's what's going on
here
a replica is sending out in fact what
I'm showing you here is various replicas
are sending out their acceptances each
replica is making its decision
independently each one is broadcasting
its decision to the other replicas in
the group and in this particular picture
one of the replicas is shown as being
failed so it's not responding and the
primary is not bothering to do this
because it already sort of said it
accepted it since it was the one that
shows the number okay now the next thing
that happens is the replicas wait for
these acceptance messages and they're
going to try and collect a quorum
certificate in containing one you know I
select number such-and-such for this
client request and the others to F of
them saying I accept that okay so this
is what I meant by form certificate
they're identical in the sense that
they're all agreeing on the same
statement okay and of course one of
these is probably coming from the
replica itself
so it knows its own acceptance and it's
waiting to hear from it heard from the
primary to sort of get itself started
and it's waiting to hear from the other
a sufficiently large number of other
replicas that they also agree ok so then
when it has that we say that the request
is prepared ok which means that simply
that everybody has managed that this
replica has managed to collect enough
assert enough messages that agree that
it has a quorum for that for that
prepare yes absolutely that's part of
the problem that's right
some of you will you know this replica
might but you need enough of them to
create the each of them have to create
their own prepare certificate in order
for us to actually carry out the the the
request and what mike is getting at is
sort of what's really fundamentally
different about this system from the
system we saw before anybody might be
lying the worst possible one to lie is
the primary because it can mislead the
other replicas in arbitrary ways and at
this point all anode knows is that
things looked ok to it but there hasn't
been any global agreement yet that
that's all right and so it wouldn't be
appropriate to execute the message right
now because you don't know for sure that
it's really going to happen
so we have to go on ok so here we are
you know we just found that we had a
prepared certificate at some replica so
when a replica has accumulated a
prepared certificate then it sounds a
message out saying I've got one ok and
it sends it to everybody ok and each
again each replica is doing this
independently and now a replica is
waiting to see whether it can't hear
from enough replicas that they all are
prepared and when it has heard about
when it receives a quorum certificate
for these prepares then it commits the
operation now it knows that the replica
group as a whole has agreed that this is
a good thing to do
ok and so at that point it's ready to
actually execute the message send the
answer back to the client one thing is
you don't execute a request
until you've executed all earlier
requests and this particular protocol is
is actually operating asynchronously so
there can be many messages in the
process of being processed and when you
finally decide that it's okay to do
number 127 you'll wait at that point in
case number 126 hadn't been done yet
yeah absolutely
each replica non faulty replica will
execute them in order okay so so non
Fawlty replicas carry out this protocol
without flaw okay so they wait to
collect the certificate they send out
the message they wait to get the all
those prepared certificates those
prepared messages they sort of create
their commit certificate then they wait
to make sure that they execute the
operation in order they execute the
operation send the answer back to the
client
okay so first of all there was one too
many numbers in your numbers so if the
clay for the primary is faulty there can
only be f- one other other faulty
replicas and that's important for the
algorithm to work properly because there
can be F total basically you were trying
to ask me what happens if there are F
failures will this algorithm be
sufficient to guarantee that the correct
result obtains yeah
mmm-hmm I'll get to that in just a
minute okay
yeah well actually no but it doesn't
really matter okay I mean so so here's
what the client actually does there
there are various forms in which you can
do that it sends it to the primary it
doesn't here after well sends it to
everybody yeah yep right yep it can't it
can't it can't do that because the
message from the client itself is
encrypted and it not only is encrypted
but it has a client-based sequence
number so that replicas can tell if I go
backwards I mean I didn't show you this
detail but if you look here on up here
you see this sort of M there well M is
something that came from the client and
it was itself encrypted in a way they
guaranteed that only the client could
have produced that and that by itself is
not sufficient it also has a sequence
number in it the guarantees that it's
the current thing thus the client wants
to do yep so so this protocol works in
various forms in one form is the client
sends this to the primary and the
primary relays it another form is the
client sends it to everybody and all the
primary has to do is say here's the
number and here's the digest of the
client message but these are sort of
little optimizations above
yes it can see it but it can't fake it
and it can't replay it okay yeah yes at
any moment in time though there's one
primary and if there were two views
there can be more than one view one
would be a majority of you the other one
would be the old view that was sort of
failing replicas will only pay attention
to the most recent view so there's
always at any moment in time a unique
replica that's acting as the primary as
far as the group as a whole is concerned
okay
now I'm not actually gonna tell you all
the other protocols what I can do is
forward you to a paper that will contain
all the gory details of the rest of it
what I showed you was sort of the normal
case operation okay and to complete the
picture there's a bunch of other things
that have to be solved first of all we
have to implement the view changes okay
and the view changes have to be done
very carefully first of all they have to
be done in such a way that any operation
that committed where it was at all
possible that the client got the answer
we have to make sure that it sort of
survives into the next view so the very
important correctness condition there in
addition the the view change has to be
done in such a way that it doesn't
interfere with liveness so you can
imagine various kinds of problems that
could arise for example if the replicas
were too fast to do a view change and
suspected the primary or imagined that a
faulty replica tried to subvert the
system by doing view changes over and
over again well then you'd have a system
that was safe you know did the right
thing but it never accomplished anything
at all so you have to have mechanisms in
the view change that ensure that on the
one hand you do view changes when the
primary is faulty and on the other hand
you don't do them too often okay and
that those details are all in some
papers that we've written on this on
this mechanism another thing is that we
need to have a garbage collection
technique in here I didn't show you how
we were accumulating all these
certificates but the fact is we're
storing them into a log and you can't
let that law grow without bound and so
there has to be a
way of shrinking the law and
periodically so that it doesn't get too
big and this this system has to also be
done careful you actually have to carry
out a protocol where the repli'd has
agreed that it's okay to get rid of the
tail of the log otherwise in certain
view change situations you wouldn't be
able to go ahead and form the new view
and then the state transfer answers the
question that somebody asked a moment
ago what happens if I have a perfectly
good replica but it somehow or other
wasn't in the act you know and so it
didn't hear about what was going on how
does it bring itself up to date and we
have a very efficient state transfer
protocol for bringing replicas up to
date the big problem with bringing slow
replicas up to date is that when you
execute operations and delete
information from the log you have a
potentially huge database that contains
all the changes that have happened in
the past and you don't want to have to
ship that whole database off when a slow
replica needs to find out information in
it so we have a very nice tree structure
sort of hierarchical system where at
high levels of the tree we have digests
that represent all the information below
them and the leaves of the tree are the
pages whatever the smallest union is
that you want to actually transfer and
we're able to carry out a protocol for
this that allows us to send just the
pages that need to be sent in order to
bring the slow replicas up-to-date okay
so this is what I would call the base
algorithm this is BFT what Byzantine
fault tolerance the base algorithm Oh
before I go on there are a whole bunch
of optimizations i've alluded to these
some of these are not necessarily
optimizations they're pessimism because
you aren't sure until you run it you
know what's going to be better and
what's going to be worse but here are
the kinds of things that you can imagine
doing for example it isn't really
necessary for everybody just send a
reply to the client it's okay if all of
but one of you send digests of the reply
because this will be sufficient to allow
the client to tell whether it has an
identical reply
we've talked already about this request
transmission it isn't necessary for the
client to send the message of the
primary in the primary relays it the
client can send every to everybody and
the primary can just send a digest along
in the messages also in our system we do
batching so the primary if we imagine a
very busy primary that's getting hit
with request after request
to request it doesn't actually start the
protocol for each request instead of
collects a batch of requests and does
one protocol for the bunch of them and
then optimistic execution this one I
think is the one that's the pessimist
cessation the idea here is that you
might reply to a read request before
you've actually executed it so sort of
out of order it's optimistic and with
optimistic stuff there's always a
question of whether it was worthwhile if
the answer is wrong it requires that the
primary collect to F +1 answers rather
than F +1 so there's a cost for it and
sometimes you have to take it back
because it wasn't just the right thing
to do yep
so the algorithm has in it very clever
techniques for doing this sort of little
dance between doing things too
frequently and doing things too slowly
and you if you look at Miguel's thesis
and I will put up a slide later saying
who Miguel is he has quite careful
analysis of some of this but I don't
think it's at the level of what you're
talking about these systems are very
hard to analyse and I doubt that we have
a precise answer to that particular
question ok all right so the system that
I describe you so for this sort of base
system has a major problem ok it allows
a system to provide good service
provided it has no more than F failures
over the system lifetime but systems
today lasts for a long time and so you
know for a fact that over the lifetime
of the system there's going to be more
than one failure or more than F failures
over the lifetime ok so we have to so we
have to we have to close that gap and so
we need a system that does exactly what
Ron just said namely it doesn't it
doesn't have more than F simultaneous
failures and we have to do this in
assists in a world in which we can't
tell who's faulty and who's not so the
big difference that one of the big
differences in this world versus the
simpler world I talked about at the
beginning of the talk is you simply
can't tell if faulty replicas may appear
to be perfectly ok because it's
answering queries and acting normally an
on faulty replica might appear to not be
ok because for example there's some sort
of denial of service attack and it's not
able to get its messages through right
now so you have no way of knowing a
priori whether a replicas failure is
faulty or not so we do something that we
call proactive recovery the idea is
we're going to periodically recover
these replicas whether they're faulty or
not and if they were faulty the recovery
procedure will correct them ok and
that's how we're going to get F the
simultaneous failures as opposed to F
failures over the lifetime of system but
the recovery has to be done very
carefully since if the replica isn't
faulty we want to make sure that we
don't
make it appear to be faulty in fact
cause things to fail and given this
technique that I'm about to describe we
can provide correct service provided no
more than FH occur in some small time
window where small is on the order of
ten to twenty minutes and the current
way that we run the system so what
you're going to want to do is you're
going to want to think about your system
how vulnerable to failures and then
you'll select a replication number that
gives you confidence that given this
window that's good enough for you
okay now the way that we do proactive
recovery is by equipping every replica
with a secure coprocessor and the secure
coprocessor stores the replicas private
key so the idea is you can't basically
the idea the secure coprocessor is it's
not possible to corrupt or get app the
information and the secure coprocessor
without physical presence you can't get
there by hacking in over the Internet
okay so the secure core processor stores
the private key and associated with is a
watchdog timer that's going to go off
periodically and tell you when to do the
proactive recovery and furthermore
there's a read-only memory that stores
the code okay so the secure coprocessor
when the timer goes off is going to
restart the node and as I said before
the recovery protocol has to be done in
such a way that it works whether the
replica was faulty or not okay and a
correct replica has to be able to keep
it state and continue processing
otherwise you can turn a perfectly
functioning system into one that doesn't
function so I'm just going to walk
through the steps here okay so now
imagine that the timer would often the
secure coprocessor said to the replica
it's time to recover okay so the first
thing the replica gets to do is it gets
to save its state okay right it's a disk
and this is a timed operation because of
course a faulty replica might refuse to
cooperate so you simply allow enough
time for an on faulty replica to save
its state and then you're going to
recover it whether it wants to or not in
the case of an odd faulty replica won't
matter it was faulty anyway okay as soon
as that time period has come up
secur coprocessor causes the system to
reboot and it reloads the code from this
read-only memory and then you can get
the state off the disk at this point the
replica has the correct code because you
took it off of this read-only memory and
if it was correct it has the correct
state as well if it was faulty and has
whatever garbage had had okay now the
next thing that happens is the replica
immediately changes its secret keys
because if this was an attack the
attacker may have stolen all the keys
and we need to be very careful not to
allow some node that's not a member of
the system to impersonate okay so if the
keys are stolen some node that's not one
of the replicas could pretend to be a
replica because it would know the right
keys to use for communication and if
that happened all bets are off because
all of a sudden we have more than F
replicas since these other nodes are
impersonating replicas so we change the
keys that this node will allow to be
used for the messages that are coming to
it that's an action they can take
unilaterally and then it sends out a
recovery request to all the other
replicas acting as a client okay so it's
simply saying to the other replicas as
if it was a client it says I want to
recover okay and when the other replicas
get this message they immediately change
their secret keys so they that's the
other side of the impersonation story
they won't accept messages from these
other replicas these these impersonators
either and through a mechanism that i'm
not going to be able to tell you about
in today's talk
they then establish a sequence number by
which time the recovery will be complete
so they're gonna say you know right now
it's at an N plus 100 the recovery will
be complete and the protocol is going to
ensure that this will actually be true
by the time you get to n plus 100 okay
now after this point the replicas just
continue doing their normal protocol
including this replica that's recovering
and this is very important because if it
wasn't faulty it needs to to act like an
on faulty replica otherwise the system
could stall or you would you would or
you might have too many failures and
meanwhile the recur
American replica is checking its state
using these digests that I talked about
and communicating with other nodes to
find out whether it state is the same as
what the other replicas think it state
ought to be and if it discovers that
it's missing some state then it's going
to fetch them using this protocol that I
mentioned of the tree structured thing
and by the time we get to n plus 100 the
recovery will be complete and the
recovering replica will have recovered
its state as well so that's the basic
idea
am i running out of time okay good
all right so I'm gonna finish up very
fast
we did some performance experiments
basically we implemented something
called bft the Siddha library that
anybody who wants can get hold of and
then we used to implement a replicated
filesystem we did NFS which is a common
filesystem and we ran it on the Andrew
benchmark which is a standard filesystem
benchmark except it's old and therefore
we made it much bigger than originally
defined so we run something called
Andrew 100 which is a hundred times
bigger than Andrew and Andrew 500 which
is 500 times bigger than Andrew and we
run it on a bunch of machines and in
particular we're doing the four replicas
to survive one failure case okay and
here's our results
this is Andrew 100 and what you can see
is that we ran three versions of the
system BFS with the full fault tolerance
turned on no replicas which is which
doesn't have any replication so we're
just running the bear algorithm on a
single machine and then the base system
and what you see here is an interesting
truth about NFS first of all you may
have thought that it's synced to disk
when you wrote something to a file but
it doesn't okay and that's why BFS no
replicas no replica and NFS have
identical performance you know our
system no replica doesn't write to disk
because we're going to rely on
replication to take care of the problem
we're writing to disk in the background
okay and we have identical performance
to NFS and that's because it's not
writing to disk either okay all right
BFS is slower and actually in this
particular case it's about 20% slower
and this
same thing is true in Andrew 500 so
we've run these experiments with both
within FS and also with Solaris and our
results show that we run anywhere from
2% faster to 20% slower we're faster
than Solaris because Solaris actually
writes to disk ok so we have good
performance and I don't really have time
to talk about this but we have actually
defined some future were some further
work that allows us to get rid of some
of these requirements of state machine
replication deterministic operations in
particular and also the the algorithm I
describes you relies on every replica
having identical state and that can be a
problem if your implementations are non
deterministic or furthermore you might
like to be able to run different
implementations at the different
replicas so those were limitations and
we have an extension to BFT called base
that overcomes those limitations by
combining Byzantine photons with a kind
of data abstraction that even allows us
to run implementations that have
slightly different specifications and so
the system as a whole satisfies an
abstract specification so this gives us
what we call opportunistic inversion
programming inversion programming is the
only way people have ever been able to
suggest that would allow you to really
survive software failures because you
can run different implementations but
the trouble is that it you really can't
start off from scratch to write for
implementations of the system if you
take off-the-shelf implementations which
are available for important services the
chances are they don't do exactly the
same thing but this technique will mask
their differences and so we can get very
nice behavior and as I mentioned a
moment ago there are co-authors in
particular this work has been done
primarily with two students Miguel
Castro who did the original work on VFT
and finished his PhD about a year ago
and Rodrigo Rodriguez who worked on the
base system along with me and Miguel
so in conclusion
we have an algorithm that's practical
and not only that but it really provides
you with the kind of behavior you want
because these systems can survive
provided they're no more than F failures
in a small time window and there's a
bunch of future work that we may or may
not decide to do by reconfiguration I
mean when I talked about replicas there
was a fixed set of replicas supposing
that you'd like to remove one and put
another one in how do you manage to make
that work
I thought proactive recovery would be
simple when I started to work on that
turned out to be hard so I wouldn't be
surprised if reconfiguration is likewise
quite hard scalability
I'm really more interested here in the
question of supposing have a great big
system how do I insert the right sets of
replicas to make the system perform with
advantages that BFT gives you without
having to provide say four copies of
every server in the system and they'd be
interesting to look at performance under
attack supposing there's a denial of
service attack or this really
administers hacker in the performance
studies I showed you we're just
proactively recovering but we aren't
trying to simulate what would happen if
there were real attacks on the system
although I must say that with the
proactive recovery because of the fact
that we run these systems under heavy
load just the very act of recovering a
replica means it loses a lot of State so
it's way behind and therefore we are
already seeing sort of the cost of what
it would be to bring a faulty replica
back up to date okay so that's it yeah
yes
I can't remember I mean these results
are in Miguel's thesis up to some number
of replicas he might not gone beyond
seven the truth is people don't
typically think of running systems like
this with more than just a to survive
more than a very small number of
failures I can't I can't invent the
analysis for you it's kind of what you'd
expect you know there's going to be the
more replicas there are the more
messages there are and these will tend
to interfere with normal case processing
so you would expect a degradation if I
think about his graph I believe the
degradation is not huge it's kind of a
small linear sort of degradation but I
should have brought his thesis with me
but I didn't yes but there's a lot of
stuff going on in the system to optimize
you know like the the group you know
handling of groups and stuff like that
that offset to some extent the kinds of
problems that you would you know you
might have fewer bigger messages for
example but yes absolutely yeah okay so
I didn't show you anything having to do
with the private keys okay everything
I'm showing you here is using secret
keys okay and hmm conventional symmetric
cryptography we use the public keys to
establish the secret keys okay and
that's done on recovery and it's also
actually done every 30 seconds so we're
refreshing those secret keys all the
time using the private keys okay
one replica right
and each replica has a key that it
shares with in fact in terrific has two
keys that it shares with another replica
one for sending messages and one for
receiving messages that was why replicas
could unilaterally throw away the keys
that they use for receiving messages
since they could still send messages but
they couldn't receive yeah so there's a
lot of secret keys floating around and
they're being refreshed periodically and
actually at a pretty fast clip
[Applause]